the dreary pomp and circumstance of the
National People's Congress
China's Parliament is usually
predictable enough covet 19 and the
economy were going to be the main
talking points instead it was Hong Kong
for nearly a year now people have
worried about Chinese troops on the
streets there but this is what a
crackdown really looks like geez these
actions and activities seriously
challenged the bottom line of the
principle of one country two systems'
they seriously damaged the legal system
seriously endanger national sovereignty
security and developmental interests
powerful measures must be taken towards
preventing stopping and punishing them
in accordance with the law Hong Kong's
Parliament the Legislative Council does
things differently from China's scuffles
broke out today after the news the
proposed security law is widely drawn to
cover acts of secession or subversion or
any attempt to endanger national
security on the Chinese mainland these
same vague laws are routinely used to
jail critics of the Chinese Communist
Party the basic law of Hong Kong it's
mini Constitution protects its citizens
freedom of speech of press of
association of assembly and of protest
the fear is that those rights will be
trumped by the security law AG announced
the bypass the legislative comes up in
Hong Kong and imposed the controversial
bill that were eroding the freedom of
Hong Kong which named as the national
security law which just result in Hong
Kong turn from one country to system to
be one country one system perhaps most
worrying China's security forces would
be allowed to set up agencies in Hong
Kong itself if Chinese secret police
were to operate in the city as they do
in China it would effectively mean the
end of the rule of law in Hong Kong the
Hong Kong government says the new laws
will not affect the rights and freedoms
enjoyed by Hong Kong nor its judicial
independence we should take a positive
feel in relation to this legislative
work of the NPC SC this is not going to
affect Hong Kong citizens rights and
freedoms that have been safeguarded by
our laws
last summer's protests were fierce over
a much less significant piece of
legislation the abandoned extradition
bill things were already set to heat up
again but this new security law isn't
just Beijing adding a little more fuel
to the fire it's pouring out a petrol
stations worth Tom Cheshire Sky News
Beijing